Before we say goodbye, we like to play a quick round of?
Drewth or Dare.
Woo!
(audience clapping)
And we have Nicole Donayquo.
Hi Nicole.
Hi.
How are you?
I'm good, I have a dare for you today.
Okay.
All right.
I dare you both to a bubblegum blowing contest.
Whoever blows the biggest bubble wins.
Oh, here we go.
Here we go.
Okay, oh, that's.
Oh wow, that's hard.
That's a hard piece of gum, okay.
Okay, I'm working her out.
(Nicole laughs)
Okay.
Are you close?
(audience claps)
The editor is close.
I'm sorry, okay, okay, hold on!
They've always said I have the strongest jaws
in the business.
So gimme a second.
Oh, I bet they do, Rossi.
(Ross giggles)
Okay, did you get one?
(audience cheers)
(Nicole laughs)
Almost.
(audience claps)
I mean, I have met New York strip steaks
that like break down easier than this.
Right?
I can blow great bubbles.
Me too.
It's a tie.
We'll just call it a tie.
Whoo!
(audience claps)
(audience cheers)
(Ross laughs)
Not bad.
Thank you, Nicole.
Amazing.
Thank you.
Good job, guys, amazing.
I'm better than this, I promise.
(Ross giggles)
(Nicole laughs)
(upbeat music)
♪ Oh oh oh oh ♪